GoPro had just launched our first camera  35 millimeter big bulky film camera on  the wrist sold for $19.99 in surf shops  so I'm checking the surf wearing the  camera and these two little kids are  going out surfing and they're in their  wetsuits carrying their surfboards and  they're jogging by me and one of them's  smudges his friend says hey look dude  he's got a GoPro and then as they run by  me and they turn around and say GoPro be  a hero and throw me a little Shaka no  advertising or anything and I remember  thinking they know our slogan and they  said it back to me  it's working by the way like a 12 year  old surfer is a very hard consumer to  reach so that they were saying our name  and slogan back to me was was really  meaningful